[Musique]
fait inédit dans les annales
universitaires les doyens des facultés
d'île de france ont appelé les étudiants
à s'opposer au front national en votant
jacques chirac
les étudiants n'ont bien sûr pas entendu
cette consigne pour se mobiliser ce
matin à l'université versailles saint
quentin on s'activait en vue des grands
rassemblements du 1er mai et des
étudiants qui sont partis sur les
différents sites de l'université parce
qu'on était au mans ce matin qui sont
partis aussi faire le tour des lycées de
saint quentin en yvelines pour informer
les lycéens les étudiants la jeunesse en
général moody's parce que l'on
je suis vraiment vraiment dégoûté ce qui
s'est passé et je pense que ça va faire
réagir la france parce que je crois que
tu vois qu'il ya trop de personnes sont
inconscients de ce qui s'est passé
des forums de discussion sont organisés
élèves et professeurs débattre des
questions qui animent le débat politique
de l'entre-deux tours et violon
professeur leur soutien est unanime et
la consigne de vote des présidents
d'universités selon justifié c'est
évidemment un petit peu extraordinaire
mais on vit dans une situation tout à
fait extraordinaire quand il ya le feu
dans la maison bah faut jouer les
pompiers donc il joue les pompiers et je
pense qu'ils ont raison c'est ce qui
confère ya propres y'a pas d'autres
choses à faire
ils ont raison de le dire ce mercredi
ils seront nombreux à manifester le
rendez vous est fixé à midi devant le
bâtiment vauban à guyancourt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un cd à 5 euros une tablette numérique à
200 euros qui dirait nous depuis lundi
matin virgin placée en redressement
judiciaire mi janvier à brader
l'ensemble de ses produits excepté les
livres avec des remises de 50 % et même
70% avec la carte de fidélité et pour le
plus grand bonheur des clients qui ont
dévalisé les magasins des fournitures
pour la future rentrée scolaire stylos
cahiers 7h à pied un peu des petits
gadgets
moi je me suis fait trop virgin bas dans
mon gros quelques jeux vidéo et puis de
trois séries animées victime de son
succès la firme a dû arrêter brutalement
sa braderie ce mercredi à 18h par
quelques selon les syndicats la
direction aurait assuré aux salariés que
les bénéfices de ces seuls dire est au
budget du plan social de la firme qui
vise 700 employés sur 960 une éventuelle
reprise de virgin permettrait de sauver
huit magasins selon les syndicats mais
l'enseigne de montigny le bretonneux
devrait fermer ses portes
hammerson le bailleur propriétaire du
groupe skywest qui ne souhaite pas
communiquer seraient opposés à la
négociation
les candidats potentiels ont jusqu'au 23
mai pour se faire connaître
date de l'audience au tribunal de
commerce de paris
[Musique]